everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today are going to be
continuing our coverage of the 2014 a
rapid World Chess Championships were in
around 7:00 for today's coverage a
whites gonna be played by Lee Kwang Liam
if you're not too familiar with this guy
he won last year in the blitz
championship so he is no stranger to
fast chess
one of the top in the world last year
being able to win the blitz formats his
opponent playing the black pieces I'm
not gonna pronounce his name correctly
but Ian nepo I'm just gonna call him Ian
I can't pronounce his last name so we'll
just call him Ian for today or the black
pieces so definitely interesting matchin
was again for those who didn't kind of
follow the coverage yesterday he was
leading the pack going into day two so
two extremely talented players going in
to round seven so I thought it would be
interesting to watch these two Duke it
out
Lee Kuan Liam decides to start with pawn
to d4 Knight f6 Knight f3 pawn to g6 and
then Bishop here to f4 I always like to
cover matches that play something
different and so I thought this one was
pretty cool not only because there are
some great players but you just don't
see kind of the London system very often
the way a london system playing pawn to
d4 in early development of a bishop here
to f4 usually solidify the pawn chain at
pawn to e3 pawn here to c3 i think this
is a pretty good way to actually play
rapid chess you you do have a very
aggressive dark square bishop which from
white can be sometimes challenging
because usually just kind of stays back
here on c1 but you don't really get in
too many complicated lines because your
pawn structure is pretty solid you're
not really trying to do too many crazy
exchanges in the senator board you're
kind of waiting developing your pieces
not doing anything too crazy first
removes from both sides are pretty
self-explanatory black's going to
fianchetto on the kingside getting ready
to castle pawn here to e3 again it I
made a video on the London system if
you'd like to kind of check that out but
these are all pretty basic move from
both sides pun here to h2 or Age
three this does allow for the bishop if
he ever wants to to bring it back here
to h2 interesting idea if he ever wants
to kind of attack the queen side so
white in this particular opening he can
cast on the King side and then throw
everything in the kitchen sink at the
Queen side he can also try to attack on
the King side as well so he kind of had
leaving himself some options he could
get pretty aggressive with his bishop or
he could decide to go ahead and bring it
back here to h2 kind of a safe Square
pawn to c5 blacks gonna do some counter
attacking in the set of the board also
wants to kind of open up the door for
his knight to get involved pawn to c3
again London system as we talked about
capture recapture so this does open up a
semi-open file for wide if he ever wants
to bring his rook over here to e1 kind
of control this that's kind of where the
the rooks you know do best as kind of
these semi open files or open files they
have more room to roam around so that's
gonna be good bishop here to e2 not
necessary to play a pawn forward to get
the bishop involved but does want to
make sure that he can castle pretty
quickly upon here to b6 getting ready to
bring his bishop involved castle on the
king sign bishop there to b7 controlling
this long diagonal right here rook over
here to e1 as we talked about just
develop both sides developing pieces
getting them into the best position on
board Knight to d7 doesn't want to block
off his bishop here on b7 Knight to do
too
he does have this pawn chain right here
so this is really the only option that
he has he can later if he wants to bring
it over here to b3 he can formulate some
sort of outpost here on c5 later into
the game he could play a little bit more
aggressive of you know Knight to e4 he
could try to exchange off a piece if
black ever wanted to come down trade off
then the knight can go ahead and
recapture so a lot of different options
with this Knight here on D - Ian now
brings his queen to c7 completing his
development so all of his pieces are
developed he's castle on the King side
both of his rooks are connected so Ian
can start to kind of formulate a game
plan if we look at what
he should really do he has one semi-open
file so we have the C file so looking to
bring his rook over here to c8 to makes
a lot of sense you usually want to have
your other rook kind of fall behind one
of your central pawns he hasn't moved as
a pawn yet so rook to e8 makes a lot of
sense to me than pushing forward with
pawn to e5 counter-attacking
but again early on your looks kind of
need to be behind it your pawns pushing
forward or controlling those long files
he also does have his bishops both
controlling these long diagonals right
here he could look to get his knight
here on D 7 a little bit more active if
we look over here from Lee Kwang Liam as
far as what he wants to do once it can
complete his development so he can get
his Queen involved he can bring in here
to see to b3 if he wants to be a little
bit more aggressive needs to figure out
what he wants to do with with this
Bishop this bishop here on e 2 isn't
very aggressive he could bring it over
here to a c4 d3 is also fine as well
it's still kind of controlling the
center of the board his Kings say so
that's fine
just a few moves and he's going to be
completing his development and
continuing with his game plan White's
now I'm gonna bring his Bishop back to
h2 kind of a waiting move I don't know
this necessary right now but that's fine
black does have to keep an eye on this
you sometimes lose this Bishop Aran h2
and forget that it's there so if he
wants to ever try something with pawn to
e6 he has to make sure that he has
something protecting this pawn here on
d6 The rifts can swing over here to d8
questionable move I think makes more
sense to me just to play rook here to c8
but you know in a fast game of chess
sometimes you try some different stuff
out Bishop back here to f1 also
questioning this you do want to kind of
open up for this rook on e want to
control the semi open file but Bishop to
d3 solves the same thing so Bishop to f1
seems a little bit passive to me but
that's what was played in the game rook
here to e8 that makes sense Bishop here
to b3 we've now come
please the development on the white side
and so both both teams going into the
middle game here we have the Queen come
back here to c8 also doesn't make a lot
of sense to me I think a more aggressive
approach may have been Bishop to d5 very
central square for the bishop it wasn't
doing too much back here on b7 kind of
forcing white to do something queen to
c8 doesn't to me seem aggressive doesn't
seem to be protecting any pieces to
really need protecting so somewhat of a
questionable move from in this
particular case pawn to a4 so Lee
decides to go ahead and start pushing on
the Queen side so it definitely has that
option this Bishop here on f1 is
protecting you know that the push up the
board so definitely has that a pawn to
a6 this kind of stops any momentum here
on a b 5 so this pawn on a 4 also acting
as an outpost if the bishop wants to
come up here to be five but pawn to e6
kind of stops any of that we now see
pawn pushing forward to a5 Black has a
few options he could just push forward
with b5 he could also capture he decides
to push down with b5 I think that's a
lot better it gets a little tricky if
you know black takes here on a 5 and
then we see the rook come up here and
capture the Queen can come to c7
threatening here the root canal swing
over to 8:1 putting a lot of pressure
again on this pawn he's also attacking
the bishop here on b7 his bishop here on
F one's also eyeing down on the square
on a6 this just gets really really
complicated in my opinion way too much
pressure on the Queen side that black
doesn't necessarily have to deal with so
again you don't always have to capture
your opponent's material in this
particular case pawn to b5 kind of stops
the the forward momentum here on the
Queen side and definitely the the better
choice I think that Ian could have taken
pawn to c4 kind of breaking this up
decides to go ahead and capture the
bishop recaptures here on c4 I think
this gives Lee a small advantage anytime
you can at capture and gain control of
the center the board get one of your
minor pieces a little bit more active
I think that's a little better off for
white in this position so as we look at
both sides white has a pretty active
position both of his bishops are doing
their job nicely this rook over here on
a1 is supporting this pawn but can't
really do too much so he may decide to
go ahead and bring it somewhere else
maybe this open C file makes a lot of
sense hopefully we also have the rook
here on e one controlling from blacks
position he's a little cramped he would
really like to get his rook over here to
c8 maybe even over here to b8 the the
rooks both here make a lot of sense he
would like to get his Knights a little
bit more active so this Bishop here on
d7 can do something the Queen back here
and see a the guiness we talked about
isn't doing much at all don't really
understand why he brought it back there
so if we look at this blacks a little
cramped from white definitely has a more
active position now pawn to a d5 kind of
stopping the attack again and the bishop
and the Queen are both attacking the
score and f7 so d5 really makes the most
sense pawn to e6 again gets a little
tricky because black can't forget about
this Bishop here on h2 can come in swing
in capture this pawn here on d6 that's
definitely going to be bad so really the
only option that Yin has here is to play
pawn to d5 the bishop is going to swing
back here to d3 still Central Square
Queen 8/8 we do kind of have this barrel
here protecting the pawn but again the
blacks kind of in the defense mode he
doesn't really have any aggression going
on at all rook swinging over here to a
c1 controlling this long file Bishop to
c6 I don't like this move again it's
it's super easy as you're doing comments
here especially in a rapid game they
just don't have a lot of time but rook
to see a challenging those files you
never just want your opponent to control
file and Bishop here to c6 not only
doesn't control that file but it's just
kind of sitting here protecting pieces
you're just using your bishops to kind
of block off this entire file so for
that reason I just think there was more
active squares for black to go Queen
comes back here to d1 Knight to e4 nice
little out
but you know what can always just
capture if you wants to but pawn to b4
Lee decides to go ahead and start
pushing on the Queen side now the rooks
in this wing over here to c8 so
definitely like that look maybe a little
bit too late but that's okay
Queen to e2 then we see an exchange
right here the bishops gonna come back
to be seven Knights over here to a b3
definitely do not want to fall into any
traps and both sides have to be very
aware of what's going on from both sides
of the board we're coming down to c1
capture pawn to e5 so Black has waited
this entire time to counter-attack in
the center of the board he has two
central pawns his opponent has one so he
thought this would be a good time to
attack again Ian really needed to move
his knight to f6 had a nice exchange and
now he can go ahead and attack in the
state of the board after the pawn takes
and the knight recaptures here on e5 all
of a sudden black has a passed pawn it
does have quite a few moves that it's
gonna have to get down here to d1 but
white for the rest of the game is gonna
have to worry about that pawn now both
sides are equal material it's about even
on board right now both sides have a few
things they have Gill inform pretty
active positions on both sides the Queen
on a eights not very very active but you
know black does have this past pawn here
on d5 than whites really gonna have to
deal with the rest of the game I'd like
to see five nice little outpost move and
then we see just the exchange of some of
the pieces the Queen here to a d3
pushing forward a little bit again still
protected by this Bishop over here on g7
and then a few more pieces come off the
board so we're starting to get towards
the end game so it's always interesting
in this particular case because again it
is pretty even black is attacking this
pawn here on before so white has to be
somewhat careful but white also has to
just be very aware of this pawn here on
d4 white now plays Bishop here to d6 he
recognizes that this pawn is gonna be
something he's gonna have to worry about
and black really wants to bring his rook
over here to d8 he
wants to have it be right behind this
pond controlling this entire file he can
start to push up the board so why it's
actually gonna bring his Bishop over
here to b6 it's a nice little outpost
typically you want to have your outpost
in the center of the board but it's not
always the worst thing on the side of
the board especially right here for a
white with this bishop here on b6 he can
kind of control the square on d8 so this
is definitely going to be very very good
for white pawn to h5 and then we kind of
see this series that we talked about
now that the rook is kind of forced to
try different approaches so he tries
rook here to e6 and it's very important
that Y continues with his game plan he
doesn't want to play Bishop taking here
on d4 because then you could see Queen
over here to d7 and this is actually
very very bad what's going to go down in
material because he now has all these
attackers on the square you can even get
his rook involved if white tries to get
his rook so definitely gonna be bad so
but in the game you know Lee decides to
go ahead and just continue with Bishop
here to b6 recognizing that there is a
trap
that iam was trying to set for him King
to h7 rook over here to d1 putting a lot
of pressure on that pond then rook over
here to e5 Queen over here to f3
definitely an interesting move
right here white definitely has to make
sure that he is keeping an eye on the
square over here on a b4 Queen to e7
and then we see pawn here to g3 and this
is definitely one of those moves that I
think is pretty interesting you're never
really sure exactly you know what's
going on but you know pawn here to g3
don't think it's quite necessary rook
over here to f5 Queen comes back there's
going to be an exchange in material but
I think this just helps black a little
bit better his pieces are a lot more
aggressive right now White's
rook here on d1 is kind of playing
defense mode or black kind of has all of
his pieces on attack mode so I think the
the few moves that we just had
err you know that the Kings not really a
lot safer the pawn on g3 wasn't doing
too much so black has definitely put
himself in a good position to kind of go
for the the wind because for a while
they were kind of tied from both sides
pawns age for trying to break up that
Queen back to d3 definitely wants to
make sure that he doesn't leave all of
his pieces kind of sitting there pawn
takes on g3 and we see the Queen come
over
Bishop to f6 black wants to start to get
more of his pieces involved into the
action King to h1 again one of those
moves that just kind of makes you you
question I think it makes a lot more
sense to get your Queen back over here
to d3 more of a centralized square your
king right away is not in a ton of
pressure so bring it over here to h1
somewhat losses and move we now see the
Queen come over here to a4 and then rook
to c1 Queen to a2 and then black just
starts to attack so we have with the
Queen and the rook now both attacking
this pawn here on f2 it pushes forward
so now the Rickson is swinging over
attacking these pieces over here brick
swings over here to f1 protecting this
pawn and then the works going to get
involved any time your opponent has
their Queen and the rook all up inside
your business down here it's definitely
going to be very difficult to hold on
for too much longer the Queen comes down
a trick comes down there to be two
attacking it a few more moves getting it
into position again both sides now
attacking our both of these pieces
attacking the square and h3 so the
King's forced to add a little bit Queen
to d6 now attacking both of this Bishop
and this pawn right here the RIC swings
up here to f2 not really sure exactly
what this piece going on f2 is doing
Queens to e4 is a lot more aggressive
still holds onto the pawn on f4 but also
attacks kind of the center of the board
it's going to be hard to really do too
much but it still seems better than rook
here to f2 again both sides getting low
on time so they don't have a ton of time
to think
because even even Ian it
he's in a good position but King to d7
pretty defensive move he's not really
under attack at all he could have easily
played Bishop here to h4 continuing the
pressure all of his pieces evolved into
the action I think that's probably a
somewhat missed opportunity for Ian on
this particular board so we have King to
g7 now the Queen comes to e4 I think
it's a little bit late because now this
rook over here to e3 is actually just
really really difficult he's just
protecting all of his pieces nicely and
then he can actually start to push
forward so the row comes back here to a3
and then black starts to push forward so
we have d3 you always want to stop your
opponent's past pawns
so the rook has kind of forced to this
defense duty making sure his opponent
doesn't push forward but bishop here to
c3 kind of forces it to move and then
all of a sudden the Queen's involved
check after the King moves the pawn
comes down here to d2 it there's just no
way to kind of stop all this pressure
and after the Rick comes down here to a1
the blitz champion from last year was
forced to resign this particular case so
Ian having a really really strong
showing after leading after day one
continue even in round seven they play
five rounds for the first three days
continuing how good he is at fast chess
so definitely an interesting game as it
got towards the middle and in game a few
key decisions from both sides took a
small air and then it just escalated
very very quickly and passed pawns you
know we talked about all the time but
past pawns are really really difficult
to deal with if you have them you need
to push them and protect them because
your opponent just they can't do
everything and the more small things you
can have against your opponent's it kind
of add up and then eventually you know
one of those usually win so hopefully
you guys are enjoying the coverage of
the rapid Championships hopefully you'll
learn a little bit and I'll see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching